let's start by correcting one thing this
wasn't really a mini budget was it this
was not just a budget but possibly the
biggest budget of well my lifetime a
generation or two it was enormous and
one way you can see that is by looking
at the scale of tax cuts we're talking
about here the higher these bars are the
more the tax cuts over various different
budgets look you can see it's going all
the way back to those Jeffrey how
Badgers in the 1980s Nigel Lawson those
famous thatcherite budgets this is
bigger than any of them look at that red
bar there that's today
the biggest actually in terms of tax
cuts since 1972 the barber budget of
1972 that led to a big boom which ended
in a crash will this be the same well
we're going to have to have a look and
see but take a step back first of all
and ask the question who is this going
to benefit the most this chart gives you
a sense of that it's called a
distributional analysis and the higher
the Ballers are the more people benefit
the more money they're getting from this
in terms of those tax cuts from the
lowest income through to the highest
income and well you can probably see the
pattern here look it is the richest five
percent who benefit disproportionately
and in large part because of that yellow
Slug there that yellow bit is the
additional rate of tax 45 that's gone
and so that money goes into their
pockets the rich just got considerably
richer it was all because for
quasi-quarters at least he wanted to get
growth higher he wanted to get back to
this kind of thing this is the growth
that we saw before the financial crisis
Trend growth so underlying growth you
could more or less expect each year and
he's decided that he wants a 2.5 growth
Target right now growth is well
disappointingly low compared with that
1.4 or so so will this work well
obviously proof will be in the pudding
but so far economists from Capital
economics think maybe it'll add a tiny
bit to that so we're still a long way
from that 2.5 percent that might be
disappointing but even more so is what's
happening in markets the pound having an
extraordinary day this is where it was
against the dollar we're just looking
over the course of the day here so from
the start of the day through to when
that speech happened the mini budget
happens and look at what happened
afterwards look at that line going down
down down down down through to there
that's the lowest it's been since 1985.
but more to the point that four about
three percent against the dollar is one
of the biggest fours one day fours that
we've ever seen on a budget day this is
just looking back over the course of the
last couple of decades at the worst days
the single worst days for the pound
against the basket of other currencies
you've got brexit there you've got many
Financial crises uh days there and look
at the Red Bar this is among the top 10
worst days for the pound in recent
history and it's the only one on that
list that comes directly from budget
decisions that's going to be something
the chancellor will be a little bit
nervous about